Welcome back, master and princess!
Hello!
Hello, howdy.
Howdy doody.
Hello!
We're here.
Here we go again.
But...
Not really.
I think.
It's like...
I just wanna explore.
And...
What's the word?
Have some stakes in it.
You know?
I wanna explore in hardcore.
That's what I'm saying.
I wanna have some stakes.
You know?
If I die, I'll never know.
But I wanna see this thing.
See the spooky woods.
The pale woods.
And I wanna see the fireflies.
And I wanna see the new cows and the new pigs and the new chickens.
Stakes are yummy.
Stake.
That title screen is a good omen if I've ever seen one.
What is it?
I thought it was supposed to be like a reference to...
What's the word?
Lord of the Rings?
Where he's like, run, you fool.
But I actually don't understand the reference.
My daughter Kasumi is sick and you wish her well.
Get better, Kasumi!
Help me feel better.
Energy beam!
Oh, fly, you fools.
Oops, sorry.
I'm not... I'm a fake Lord of the Rings fan.
Don't let Mike distract him.
Stop.
February 24th is my birthday, so please sing me a birthday song, Mito-chan.
I love you today, too, Kouyuu-chan!
Thank you so much!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Kouyuu-chan.
Happy birthday!
It's a very, very old game called Sinistar.
Oh, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
Yesterday was my 30th birthday, the 23rd.
Fast food, happy belated birthday!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vasude.
Happy birthday!
Spank, thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
So, guys, let's ignore this.
I just was, like, exploring.
I was just exploring, but today we're going to make a new world.
The new world will be called Newer World.
Just exploring, just exploring.
And I was also trying to...
I saw some videos of, like, things to make in Minecraft, so I wanted to test it out.
What's experiments?
The music is so strange.
Yeah, newer means better.
Always.
What's experiments?
Like, human?
Wacky world settings.
Experiments are potential new features.
Be careful, as things might break.
Experiments can't be turned off after world creation.
Oh, updated trades for villagers.
Improved movement for minecarts.
I don't think I'll ever use these, but I guess we can try it.
Oh, Newer World.
We've already upgraded.
Yeah, I just felt like playing some Minecraft, but I don't have, like, a server or anything that I...
that I can explore in, so...
Oh!
Are you kidding me right now?
I was about to say, oh, wow, we're in a dark wood.
Oh!
Guys, if this ain't some streamer luck nonsense going on here...
Look, even the sky becomes gray.
If this isn't some streamer luck nonsense...
Give us the seed.
How do I give the seed?
I hear an eerie noise.
Darn, she's good.
Oh, I hear eerie noises.
It's so creepy.
I forgot about music because I was listening to Minecraft music.
What do I do now?
Oh, slash seed.
There you guys go.
There you go, everybody.
If you would like to spawn into your own world immediately with the pale world right next to you...
Dozo.
Punch wood.
Yeah.
What is this biome called again?
Pale garden.
Well, I gotta get some, like...
I have a question, if anybody knows.
Do monsters still spawn in here besides the creaking?
Or, like, is it one of those kinds of biomes where nothing else can spawn except him?
Yes?
Oh, golly.
Okay, we gotta get some...
I can't believe it.
I was ready.
I was so ready for our epic adventure.
Imagine I'm also beating this.
And we get the heart of the little guy, the creaking man, too.
I can't believe it right now.
And it's huge.
It's ginormous.
I hear stuff.
Oh, I hear stuff.
And there's a second part even.
How am I supposed to tell when it's night?
Or turning to night, everything's so gray.
I can't, I'm so, I'm stun-locked right now.
I'm stun-locked.
Just like London.
So true.
So nice of them to make...
Not to turn, you know, the UK into a biome.
And look, here's the other one.
I saw like a little, what's it called?
Oh wow, there's even a thing underneath.
Oh,
this scene is amazing!
What?
Oh my gosh.
I, I kind of want to start over.
Like, I, I feel like...
I feel like I should die and start over.
Because it was too easy!
What the heck?
Oh my gosh, I need to get food.
But there's no animals anywhere in sight.
We got some logs.
Let's go find some food.
And, oh, food!
Sorry, sorry, your food.
Oh wait, hold on, let me make a sword.
Or something.
I'm so, I'm so shocked.
I'm shooketh, literally.
So, oh, stick.
Sword.
Alright, here we go.
Come here and dinner.
He's not even an interesting color, uh, chicken.
Like, I thought they changed the colors of the chickens.
Let's do... you.
I, wow, wow, and it's like surrounded!
Oh my gosh, all this green in the midst of the, the gray.
Wow, oh no, it's burning.
It's burning up!
Okay.
Great landscape.
Yeah, for real.
Uh.
Oh wait, actually, hold on, I'm gonna make a shovel too.
Oh wait, I need more stick.
And shovel.
And we'll make a pickaxe too.
Yeah, we'll make, we'll make everything.
We'll make everything.
I was about to say, oh, there's a lush cave too.
And then we came into the, the whole area of it.
Because I saw the tree.
The little green tree.
Let's try and go around to the other side.
It's so quiet.
Should I put on music?
Oh, the flowers!
These light up at night!
Wait, I'm taking one.
I've been sick!
Why are you sick?
Since I got back from Japan, I've been vodgaing for the past week.
But I want to tell you I love you, have a safe trip to Japan.
Thank you!
Feel better, Ashes!
Pirate pop quiz?
Oh no, okay.
What be a pirate's favorite letter?
I know this one!
Arr!
Uh, hold on.
Ooh, I hear the creaking!
I hear the creepy noise!
Oh my god, there's an axolotl!
Oh, there's some iron.
Let's grab it.
Some good, good, good.
No, it's E?
Oh.
Matey.
Wait, can I...
Do I need a...
Wait.
Do I need a thing?
Hello Minto, can I get a happy birthday?
Happy birthday!
How do I say your name?
Dekotob?
Wait.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Dekotob.
Happy birthday!
Time to walk the plank.
Everyone knows that a pirate's favorite letter is the C!
Well, um, I guess...
I guess I gotta walk the plank.
How many do...
Oh, I need more stick.
Stick.
Wait, how do you do stick?
All right, U.
All right.
And so far, we look like we're good on time.
Nice.
Iron this early is so good.
Let's go.
Did you guys see the axolotl over there?
And there's...
We can probably go down and get some of the coal that's out around there too.
Oh, I'm gonna put on BGM.
I thought the BGM would...
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I think I played once and the BGM was like almost consistent.
So I was like, oh, I think they adjusted the BGM to be more all the time.
And so I was like, oh, okay, we're just gonna have...
I'll just play a BGM.
I don't know.
We'll do this.
Okay.
Cool.
He's down there!
He's down there.
All right.
I'm going through.
I'm going in.
We'll make...
What's it called eventually?
A...
I mean, I gotta make a house.
I gotta make a bucket.
I gotta get more iron.
I see coal.
We gotta get coal.
I could just jump into the water, but...
All right.
What if I make this my home?
The home of the creaking.
There's a little fish in here.
Ah!
And me.
Oh, gosh.
There he is!
He's so cute.
All right.
I saw coal over here.
Let's go grab this.
I gotta make my food.
True mountain home.
Yeah.
Hopefully there's nothing in here.
I'm scared.
Nothing spawn, please.
Wait.
Torch.
We'll just make some immediately.
All right.
All right, we're good.
Okay.
What do I do now, you guys?
We were supposed to go on an epic adventure and now we're just...
We're here.
What do we do?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
If you find a cute animal, can I ask you to name it something funny?
I suppose we can.
We already found an axolotl.
Beat the ender dragon.
Okay.
Okay, you guys...
I'm no Minecraft veteran anymore.
Wow, this is a huge...
vein.
This is perfect.
How did we get so lucky?
Uh-oh, it's starting to get dark though.
And I don't have a bed or anything.
What do I do?
Where do we go?
I'm so scared.
I only have one food.
Let's see.
Let's make a...
Let's make...
What's a furnace?
Now, welcome...
to our abode.
The great...
Minto...
place.
Hopefully nothing spawns.
And...
It's our...
It's the hole.
Yeah, it's our little...
It's our little hidey hole.
And we're fine, probably.
Look, I can set these up and they'll be lit.
Or I...
Oh!
Awaken!
It's nighttime.
Nevermind.
I'm gonna put this right here.
We're just gonna...
Put this here on top of it.
Wow, very trendy.
Everybody's doing this now.
And...
I don't need tropical fish.
We'll cook our iron and we'll cook our food after.
And we'll start digging.
We're just gonna start digging out our new home.
More iron!
Oh my gosh.
How did we get so lucky?
I was so ready to traverse the world.
Now I don't know what to do.
I was like, okay, I'll find the creaking and then I'll...
I mean, technically, I haven't found the creaking guy.
He's out there though.
He's above me literally at this very moment.
Is this seed blessed?
Maybe.
He's out there creaking.
That's so mean.
You can't just call...
You can't just call, you know, 30 year olds the creaking.
Thought I should ask an expert going to a concert in Japan next week and heard of...
Concert earplugs.
Are these normal for lives in Japan?
Oh, that's a great question.
Honestly, they are not.
At least for idol shows.
I never see anybody wearing them.
But I would...
Especially if you go to a small show.
100% recommend them.
I always wear them at small shows.
Actually, thank you for reminding me because I'll need to...
I need to...
What's a word?
I need to pack mine.
But...
Yeah, I would definitely recommend wearing them.
Bigger shows too.
But I feel those ones aren't usually as bad as like the small venue places.
Because at the small venue ones, they just...
They just crack that music so loud.
It's so, so bad.
But usually at bigger venues, it's not so bad.
Dort!
Let's make our food.
Oh, not quite yet.
Dort.
Have fun!
Yeah, it's really...
I regret having never used more like the earplugs...
Uh, long ago.
All right, we got...
We got one food.
Our only...
Our only snack.
Our only meal.
Is there anyone out there?
I mean, the creakings out there, we know for sure.
That guy.
How many of them are there, you think?
Just got back from a trip and have to catch up on vibes.
But want to know something odd that was happening because of Minecraft movie.
Warner Bros started to copyright a bunch of videos using Minecraft music.
But it's fine now, I think.
What?
No way.
Oh wait, um...
Take this back.
Make more torch.
I'm so...
I'm kind of salty about my flowers not blooming.
Oh, there's more axolotls.
Wait, so there's axolotls out there, but there's no...
Like, creepers and things?
I don't want to accidentally destroy the ecosystem at the moment.
Maybe later.
But at the moment, I don't want to, you know.
But we're...
I mean, we're really high up anyway, so...
There was like a new...
What's it called?
Trailers of the Minecraft movie.
It's just...
What's...
What is it about?
It's finally my birthday!
Blue's Clueless.
May pretty please get a mother base happy birthday.
Of course!
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday, with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Blue's Clueless!
The Midcraft movie.
Yeah, they probably...
The flowers probably don't work in...
In caves.
You're probably right.
I'm still gonna be...
Sad about it, though.
We'll just have to hold...
We'll just...
We're in this tiny hole.
We're in our hidey hole until daylight.
Until we can get a few more resources.
Maybe I can even make armor.
Well, I gotta make tools first.
Like iron...
Axe and...
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Oh, there it is.
There it goes.
J'mon G3.
I think there's anything out there.
The creaking is out there somewhere.
Lurking.
She's out there.
No one's in my cave yet, though.
Well, this area is actually...
Oh, there's a creeper.
I just saw him go down the water slide.
I was gonna say this area is pretty empty, actually.
All things considered.
Surprising.
Hot dog.
Hot dog, indeed.
Logan, thank you so much for the tank gift!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have you seen the Minecraft movie Steve Figure?
It's literally just a Jack Black figure.
Which makes sense, but it's still funny.
Oops, I forgot to make a new pickaxe.
That's so lazy.
That's so bad.
It's awesome.
Do you think...
Okay, let's see.
We have 11.
This takes two, so we'll make a sword.
Oh, no!
I do feel like we need some iron...
Some...
Some armor, though.
The sun is rising!
Nice.
Default Jack.
Default Jack Black.
I'm just...
So curious what the movie will be like.
Will I go see it?
Most likely not.
Maybe it will be...
Maybe it will exceed all of our expectations, which are currently none.
Seeing it for the FOMO?
I don't think I would have...
I mean...
I don't think I have a FOMO.
I even hate watch.
I'm still watching it.
If it's accidentally good...
See, part of me is just like...
I love Jack Black so much.
I don't want to believe that anything he's in could be bad, but...
This just doesn't...
It's just not hitting.
There it is.
Okay.
Yearn for the minds.
Okay, it's probably daylight now.
We could probably leave.
I remember not being too excited about the LEGO movie.
See?
Exactly.
It could be very similar.
Like I said, we just need to see it exceed our expectations.
Just a little bit.
Ouch!
Okay, let's go find some food.
And light up this area a little bit.
Is that creeper gone?
Please say yes.
Also, I'm gonna put...
I'm gonna put these out here too.
Gosh, this area is so difficult.
Oh, can I not?
Okay, we can put it on the moss.
Maybe it'll work.
We'll see.
It's our little pathway back home.
I think he's gone.
Also, there was one other thing I really wanted to see.
And that was the firefly bushes, you guys.
We have to find the firefly bushes.
That's important to me too.
Mario movie?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everyone said...
Everyone booed the Mario movie too.
So true.
Oh, this would have been an even better...
Okay, everybody, we're relocating.
We're relocating.
This is an even better hidey hole.
Okay, let me go get my stuff.
Gosh, it's so hard living in the best...
Generated seed ever.
Too many options.
The real estate is going insane.
Location...
Wait, but what about my little...
Okay, this is our garden.
Because we're living the true high fancy life.
Luckily, I don't have much that I own.
Luckily, I'm pretty broke.
All right.
Ouch!
Oh gosh, I keep forgetting we need to get food.
And you can't eat any of these fish.
Can't eat that fish.
You can't eat axolotls.
They keep just...
They keep leaving the fish out to taunt me.
They're like, aren't you hungry?
Okay, wow!
This is a home.
Lots of greenery.
Mhm.
What's that saying?
If you have a crafting table, it's a home.
Wow!
It's so gray today.
Fancy people eat...
I don't think you can eat axolotls.
I think they're actually, like, endangered.
Actually, I think they're quite endangered now.
Just like London.
Anybody feeling at home right now?
All right, we really gotta go get food.
We might have to venture out a little bit.
Because I also need to find a way to make a bed.
I don't want to dig if I have no food or anything, but...
Oh gosh!
It's calling to me to go down there.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's pretty tempting.
The British biome.
I know!
How nice of them.
They really wanted...
Anybody in Britain playing this to feel at home.
Nice.
Stop trying to raise Koyu!
She's mine!
Stop trying...
No!
Stop it!
In my chat!
I don't know if anybody saw that.
Never stop trying.
Time and place!
Oh gosh, we gotta be really careful, you guys.
Okay, how do I get up?
We'll dig our way up.
This is Minecraft!
Wait, why did I do that?
Dig our way up!
Koyu cute though?
Yeah, Koyu very cute.
No!
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to get this.
I'm being greedy.
Okay, all right.
We're almost out.
No, we're not.
I mistook the stone for trees.
Minecraft?
By what?
Cruft?
Minecraft.
Use your PTSD for what?
Thank you for the pink joy.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, what a lovely day today.
A lovely gray day.
Ouch!
Oh god.
Oh, we need food, you guys.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
I need precious animals.
I need precious animals around.
Wait, I think I saw...
Nope, that's a flower.
Shoot.
Um, I can't...
I can't die this fast.
It's only been 30 minutes.
I'm starving.
Animals do spawn in here, right?
Mushroom soup?
Oh, mushroom soup.
Wait.
Oh my god, it's a goat.
Can I eat this?
Does that...
Can you eat that one?
It's so empty in here.
I can't run any further.
I can't run anymore.
I'm too slow.
No, please.
Okay, I think we got it.
I'm afraid of the powdered snow.
Gosh, this biome is ginormous.
Guys, if I die from powdered snow, it's really over.
Oh gosh.
I think I see a chicken.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Yeah, that's a chicken.
Oh yeah, we got food.
What did I just grab?
Oh, pale oak sapling?
From where?
From homest...
Oh, more chicken.
More chicken, more chicken, more chicken.
Yes.
We'll take their eggs too.
Nice.
The ground.
Interesting.
I didn't know you could pick up a...
So how do I make a mushroom soup?
How do I make that?
Oyako don time.
No.
I only got six here.
I don't think I've ever...
You need a bowl.
Oh yeah.
Soup store.
Red and brown mushroom.
I only have red!
All right, I hear more chicken.
Yes.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, wait.
I saw a brown.
Did I know?
No?
I thought I saw a brown.
Oh wait, there's one all the way over there.
You can hear the...
It sounds different when you walk on the leaves.
Kind of cute.
It's kind of nice.
There it is, there it is, there it is.
Pig!
Okay, nice.
More food.
What we need...
Oh, sheep!
Big, big news, big news.
We need the wool.
Oh, I hear a skelly!
They're like right below me.
Oh, I hear them.
This is why I didn't want to...
Wait.
I didn't want to go into the...
Into these woods because...
It's kind of spooky.
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm scared.
Are we gonna make it back in time?
It's starting to get dark.
Guys?
Oh, guys.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Sorry.
I'm scared.
Um, we found him!
Can I kill him?
Oh my god.
Sorry!
Holy mo...
You guys, I'm gonna die here.
I just have to...
I can't move.
I have to...
I have to just try the axe.
I have no axe!
Uh, would you like a brown mushroom?
Okay, I'm gonna eat some raw chicken.
That was a bad idea.
Uh, hmm.
Build a wall.
True, true, true.
Hey, hey!
This is mine!
Uhum.
Now...
Now I'm...
...safe.
Can we get up here?
No, it doesn't seem to be the case.
We just gotta keep building up, because I don't want a skelly to knock me off.
Okay.
Alright, no skelly is gonna get us up here.
This is so stupid!
No!
Oh, he's gone.
I saw his heart though.
It was like somewhere in this tree, I think.
I wish I had a...
What's it called?
An arrow, bow and arrow, so I could like shoot him?
Make food?
I could...
Let's see.
Alright, we gotta make a... Did I get it?
Okay, yeah.
Let's make... Alright, new house everybody!
A furnace?
Alright.
What a beautiful night it is.
Oh, that's a really deep hole.
And there's an Enderman around!
Okay.
I'm also gonna make a new axe.
Once I make more wood.
A shield!
Ah, so true.
We'll make a shield.
That's big.
That's important.
Big importance.
Okay.
Don't blink, blink and you're dead.
They're fast, faster than you can believe.
Scary, scary, scary.
Do you think it's in here?
The heart.
We're gonna dig for it.
We're gonna see.
I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna risk it too much though.
Gosh, these are really thick trees.
Please eat.
Bye!
I think it was this tree.
You can see the flowers are lit up.
Wait, what just...
What just happened?
Oh, my furnace.
Furnace.
Alright.
I got one wool.
Let's do some more iron too.
Iron.
Maybe it wasn't this tree.
It's hard to tell though.
I'm gonna keep...
I'm gonna keep digging in here though.
Is that him?
No.
Nice shield.
Thanks.
I got it.
This is so scary, you guys.
I wasn't prepared for this.
What was I thinking?
Let's have a relaxing little...
Is that Skelly?
Where is that Enderman?
I can hear him.
Wait, I see it.
It's right there.
You guys see all that...
All that stuff in there.
That's what will make the heart.
That's surrounding the heart.
There's a couple Endies in here.
Oh my god.
Wasn't it just such a nice night though?
Right?
Some annoying neighbors.
Truly.
OK.
Nice.
Let's grab my cobblestone.
Let's grab my stuff.
Creeper.
I saw a creeper.
I didn't see anyone.
I hear him, but I don't see him.
Let's see.
What else do I have?
Just six...
There he is!
Hi!
You wish you could get up here.
I don't have enough wool for a bed.
We are kind of stuck at the moment.
Creeper top right.
You guys?
Oh my gosh.
Creeper real.
You were actually right.
Wait, there's two of them.
There's two creepers down there.
The night is long.
It's long.
What's that over there?
It's like glinting.
You see that?
Something shiny all the way over there.
You think it's fire?
We'll go check it out in the morning.
What is that?
Fire?
Oh, it's getting bigger.
A little bit.
Maybe it's a fire from some lava.
Or just lava.
I think that's definitely a fire.
Creeper bottom right.
The zombie completely left us alone.
That guy is so lame.
Creeper bottom right of screen.
Wait!
The sun.
The sun is rising!
Wait!
No, I can still see the shiny.
The sun is rising!
Yippee!
We made it!
Being a coward pays.
Guys...
If someone says, wow, she's totally...
She's totally cheating.
We lived.
Sunlight!
Alright, when does everything start to burn?
Alright, good night!
Good night!
Creaking crumbles.
Yeah!
Zombie hurt!
Alright.
We're about good to go down, I think, again.
Things will start to...
Oh yeah, let's get my... I guess I can take this back home.
Doesn't hurt to have an extra, right?
I was just gonna leave it here in case.
Oh wait!
Did you guys see that?
I hear skellies.
I hear... Oh my gosh.
There he is.
Alright.
Alright guys, we're gonna take a strategic...
It's not strategic.
We're gonna take a beautiful above the tree tour of the area.
Have you ever wondered what it's like to live in the trees?
Well, on this tour, I can tell you.
Why didn't I do this before?
Why didn't I just leave like this?
I think I messed up.
This is how I could've gotten home.
Alright guys, we do need to leave here though.
We found the creaking, we saw him.
He was very, absolutely spooky.
I hear a more eerie noise.
Now look at this house!
Now that's a livable cave.
That's a livable cave.
The fireflies, correct me if I'm wrong, I believe you can only find them in a swamp biome.
Is that true?
Minky the cave diver.
Near rivers too.
This
is such a beautiful home.
We got a lot of iron and...
What's it called?
Coal out of it.
Hello, I'm home!
We have a pink axolotl now too!
The family is growing.
We must traverse outside too.
Hold on, I'm going to go grab this coal.
We're going to grab a little bit more supplies from this area.
Welcome home, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, anything in here?
Some more supplies, perfect.
Nice, nice.
Nice...
Wow, nice.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Okay, and then there was some coal here.
We'll go cook this up, we'll give ourselves some armor.
And we shall be good to go.
Gosh, this is such a terrifying place to...
This is such a great and such a terrifying place to start.
What a seed, wow.
I'll have to show you guys the other one that I was looking at.
Because it was also something...
Like, I feel that maybe the Pale Gardens...
I know that they spawn by dark oak places, you know?
But I feel like maybe they are often by lush caves too.
I've only had experience with two of them, and both of them were in this type of area.
Can you share the seed?
I did earlier.
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Hopefully you had time to grab it.
Hello!
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Any study advice on Japanese 1001 first test?
Um...
Any... Any... Any advice?
Uh...
Remember...
Um...
Yabai.
And you'll sound so native.
Just anything?
Yabai.
It's so funny when I listen to, like...
Young girls speak in Japanese.
Like, you know, if I'm shopping or something and I hear the girlies talking.
The way they talk is so specific.
And it's always like this.
How do I... I'm just trying to...
Um, today...
Um...
I don't know how to say it.
Maybe...
Yuta-senpai...
They always...
I'm like...
I'm like, how do you get to...
It's like the girls who say like after every... Where is my home?
Who say like after every word.
So like... I was like...
Oh my gosh, like...
It's literally the same thing.
Just in a different language.
Japanese valley girl.
But all the girlies sound like that now.
It's so funny.
Where's my house?
Oh, there it is.
Dirt.
I need to put a...
My house is not safe anymore.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh, 28 pieces.
We're killing it.
Japanese zoomers.
Exactly.
It's hiragana, katakana, grammar and some vocabulary.
I think for katakana, always be careful of tsu and shi.
You know?
They look so similar.
To the untrained eye.
Like mint, that's like so funny of you to like say.
Japan or Florida.
You know how from Ore ga iru?
Is a good character.
What does she do that?
Sushi?
No, tsu and shi.
Not sushi.
How did I get these saplings?
I was literally wondering earlier.
I was like, how do you get saplings of these trees?
Oh, it's so gray.
Another gray day.
Alright, well let's go gather some more supplies while that cooks.
Sushi.
No sushi.
I mean, yes sushi.
Stop, you guys are gonna make me hungry.
You guys are gonna make me hungry.
Where do you think the source is?
Not here.
Okay, wait, we can get it from here.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's go down.
I'm gonna perform the bucket.
For my first trick, I will perform the bucket saving life trick.
How will I get back up?
Okay, never mind.
I will perform it another day.
Okay, here we go.
Wait, there's more creaking trees down here?
Oh, that's not good in there.
Oh gosh, we're already this low?
We're already at 15 degrees.
Is the creaking in here too?
Oh, hello.
I'm such a baby.
Gosh, okay, we gotta get this...
Is it starting to get nighttime or is it just, you know, the area?
I can't tell.
Okay, nice.
Here we go.
More iron.
Guys, I think I messed up.
We're gonna have to wait out the night again.
This sucks.
Look all down there.
There's so much going on in this little area.
You can make wool from spider string.
Maybe a spider will come and grace us with its presence.
I did think about that, but it's a little...
A little less reliable than just finding some sheep.
Maybe some spiders will come and...
Grace us.
Well, I don't wanna light up the area then.
I don't want my area...
I don't want this place to explode because of a dang creeper, you know?
What do we do?
I don't have a...
I don't have a bed or a door.
I have nothing.
I only have a little bit of food.
We're not doing so hot, huh, guys?
Okay, one of these will give us a chicken.
One, two...
Dang it.
There's a creeper over there.
Right there.
That's not a spider.
I don't wanna go into the creaking!
Let's go gambling?
Okay, nothing can get in here, right?
Alright, time to dig.
Dig a tunnel, dig, dig a tunnel.
I hear axolotls.
Maybe not this way.
Okay, we're gonna change direction.
This way.
Okay.
Alright.
You guys, some of you guys will be like foaming at the mouth for this seed.
You'll be like, oh my gosh, this is the best seed ever.
Here I am, fighting for my life.
Oh.
It's like the luckiest seed.
I just can't believe that we got to the area first try.
My afterlife?
Well, it's technically my life in Minecraft, so...
You're trying to um actually my terminology?
You're just like, uh, Minto is actually your afterlife.
Nemi Nightmare!
Thank you for the raid!
Raining?
Nemi, have you ever... Oh my gosh.
Whoa, this rain is coming down hard.
Have you ever seen a creaking Nemi?
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Murphy.
Have you ever seen a creaking?
Guys, should we go show her?
Let me make some more armor.
What a creaking.
Let me make my armor and then I'll show you.
I'll be brave.
I will be brave!
Um, we got our shield.
We got our sword.
Off we go.
Okay.
Cabo, thank you for the tag.
Wait, the flowers are bloomed!
Awesome.
Alright, let's find a way to the creaking.
First I must...
But hello!
I hope you had a good stream!
Hello, Naplings.
Welcome.
I'm... I'm... Okay.
You know what?
I'm just gonna build up.
We could die here.
That's our risk to take.
Snow in there.
Okay, we're in.
We're in.
Creaking!
Does it not rain in here?
It's so scary.
That's a skelly.
Ouch!
Stop!
Stop it.
It's not cute.
Ouch.
Stop.
It's not cute.
We're destroying the environment.
That's okay though.
It's just a spider.
We gotta find a creaking.
Alright, take its wool.
We're fine.
I'm stuck in a hole.
We're looking for a creaking.
Wait, I think I heard one.
Why does it gotta be extra spooky with the rain?
I can't see anything.
Eat?
Oh yeah, thank you.
That's all our food.
That's all we got left.
Wait, hold on.
That's all we got left, everybody.
I was gonna make a torch.
Nevermind, I can't.
Let's go find a creaking.
Look how beautiful though.
Creaking!
Is it really this hard to find one?
Maybe we should go back to where we found before.
Low HP run.
Let's let go.
Creaking!
I'm scared.
I thought I saw one over there.
It was over this way, I know.
I remember.
Oh my gosh, baby zombie.
Leave me alone!
I forget everything is stronger in hardcore mode.
Another Zombo.
Creaking, don't go!
Hello Enderman.
Another Zombo.
Another Zombo?
Where?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, guys?
Sayonara!
Guys!
No!
Creaking!
That's the creaking!
There's two of them!
There's two... I'm so dead.
I'm so dead.
Sayonara, everybody.
It was a nice life.
Dug up soda!
And the sun was coming!
How big is this area anyway?
My goodness.
Oh my gosh, it was a nice life.
Was it?
Nice as...
Look at this.
This spawn is so crazy though.
Wow, we should've just gone in here.
It would've been so beautiful.
What the?
Oh yes, this is...
Yeah, this is where the... I was gonna say there's a tree all the way in here.
Yeah, this is the tree.
Respectable attempt.
Gosh, I really tried to...
To build up.
Only too late.
The tree, the tree got me.
Oh, that's right.
We can't fly too far.
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh, it's loading in slowly.
No, load!
We were here!
My first home, I promise.
Misadventure from trying to show off to a girl.
I was able to show the creaking.
There was two of them, they were coming after me.
This seed is so... Wait.
I don't know if I've ever... I've never put in a... Like a...
A biome...
You guys, if we had dug far enough...
If we had dug far enough, we would...
If we had dug far enough, we would've been in even more trouble.
We would've been in the biggest trouble.
How does this always happen to me?
Oh my goodness.
But yeah, I kind of want to go back into this world, but like fly around a little bit.
I just want to see... You know, since it doesn't load all the way.
This is so... I love when the...
The mossy biome grows into a mine shaft.
So pretty.
Yeah, I tried showing off to a girl.
Yeah, and what?
Yeah, I tried...
I still got the mission accomplished.
I found the creaking.
He was coming after me.
Maybe.
Hold on.
What was the scene?
Okay.
Can I... Can I copy this?
Click to copy.
Paste.
I'll paste it in chat for you guys too, in case anybody wants to...
Wants to see also.
Hold on.
Now we save and quit.
If I...
Single player.
Create new world.
World.
Seed.
Create.
So let's just do... Create a new world.
I just want to see the size of the...
The biome.
You know?
Cause it's... I think this is like...
It's so expansive.
And this is where we were.
And this is where I died.
Like right over here.
Yeah, I was like right about here when I died.
Oh my god.
That's so much.
Look, it continues all the way over here.
All the way over here.
But we must try again, because we... This time for sure we'll go find the...
Fireflies.
This time for sure.
Oh, it was a lava pit.
Wow, there's more on the other side.
All the mushrooms.
What an insane spawn point.
Good.
Next world.
Shall we travel to the next adventure?
As much as I want.
I love... Look at these.
Look at the flowers on the ground.
It's too cute.
It's so cute.
I hope they do the same, but with a...
Hold on, I'll show you guys something.
With the leaf litter.
Look at this.
I wonder actually if there's a good way to show this off.
Hold on.
Oh yeah, you can see it here.
Look at the gradient.
It like... It goes like more monochrome.
And then...
It goes from monochrome and then it goes into the brown.
Hold on.
Isn't that so cool?
Depending on the biome.
Isn't that so neat?
The gray to the brown to the brown.
I like the leaf litter a lot.
I think it's so pretty.
Oh, whoops.
You can really see it here though.
Here, let's do... Let's do... Yeah, you can see it.
Actually, let's do...
Like that.
There we go.
There you go.
Science.
Alright.
Create new world.
Newest.
This is Firefly...
World.
I can't type today.
Hardcore.
On experiments.
The real world.
We have found the fireflies.
We have found...
Why does this keep happening to me?
We have Minecraft music.
OK, we'll take these for later.
Maybe there are some other ones.
Or something.
Where...Minecraft, where is your sense of adventure?
Kiwawa!
Wait, where is the Wawa?
Hi Kiwawa, I miss you.
Wait, WTF.
Kiwawa, I saw that you also were looking for the creaking in your new holo server.
My last game literally spawned right in the bio.
Right in it.
I didn't have to do anything.
But I want to do something.
I want to search and explore.
I want to be an explorer.
I want there to be stakes.
High stakes.
Hacker girl.
I'm not.
The music disappeared.
I'm just gaming I suppose.
There is more of them.
I guess maybe these are easier to find.
I mean before we were in the mountains so...
Oh my gosh!
Do you see what I see?
Fuzzy cow!
Look how cute.
How am I supposed to kill this for food?
How am I supposed to kill this guy for food?
He is so fuzzy and cute.
Oh my gosh.
He is so cute.
Amazing.
Mission complete.
That right there is why he is the best boss.
No violence.
Let's see.
Let's start making some...
Sticks and stuff.
I don't know.
Stop trying to risk people in my chat.
Master Gandalf.
Goodbye.
You said you wanted some high stakes.
Are the chickens here also cute?
Let's see.
Let's find some chickens.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna have to kill this cow for food.
Sorry.
I know you are so cute and fuzzy.
I'm really sorry.
Dog!
Wait, I heard a chicken.
Chicken?
Oh my god!
Look at him!
Look at that guy.
No rizzing allowed in chat.
Not in front of my salad.
Oh my god!
There is another one over here.
Wait, they added... That's right too.
They added the dog personalities.
Like the dogs have different barks where they go.
They have different barks and stuff now too.
Hello dog.
Dog?
Okay.
It's feisty.
I need to test different kinds of cinnamon.
Anything you recommend I bake.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know why my first instinct was to tell you to do the cinnamon challenge.
You know where you take the cinnamon and you put it in your mouth on a spoon?
You could do that.
We gotta go find some coal.
Chat, get pregnant.
Stop!
What are you trying to take over?
Oh, nice.
Trying to take over the stream.
It's not your place.
Yeah.
Yes?
Oh, good.
Okay, nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, nice!
Yay, hole.
Chat, I will always advocate for you guys to use protection.
Protection.
Every time.
Protect yourself.
The world is scary.
Like helmets?
Yeah, exactly.
You don't want to get into an accident.
That involves another human being.
If you get into an accident...
You know, it should be from your own...
Your own...
Stupid self.
Oh, yeah.
Some more chicken.
This chicken better taste different.
This chicken has better insulated feathers.
So it's gonna taste good.
Nice and juicy.
Get out of here.
Any iron?
Iron.
You guys, you wanna know one of my favorite things about Takanashi Kiara.
Hopefully she's gone.
But I love the way she says Bayomi.
Bayomi.
Iron.
She says, we gotta go find that Bayomi.
It's so cute.
Are there Chihuahua dogs?
I don't think so.
I hear lava too.
Lava is somewhere.
Maybe underneath us.
It's the better pronunciation.
I agree.
Can I ask when you'll give us wave 3?
In patience.
In due time.
Wave 3 will happen.
Actually, I was hoping it would happen sooner.
But...
There have been some delays.
Alright, we gotta... Okay, I'm gonna go get that coal.
And then we're gonna...
What do I do now, you guys?
I have no purpose.
I have no purpose now.
Everything that I wanted to do in this stream has been completed literally as soon as I logged in.
Try to find fossils?
What?
This is a wrong game.
I think you don't... I don't think you know what...
Desert.
Okay, true.
True, true, true.
They added also some stuff to the desert.
Like, some ambiance.
And...
And other things.
We'll find a desert!
Is there copium in the desert?
I don't cope ever.
Finding fossils is no biggie.
Wait.
There's actually fossils?
Fossils?
Fossils have been a thing in Minecraft for years... Wait, what?
There's fossils in the game?
Yeah?
Wait, what?
I've never... What do you mean?
For years though.
There are bone block structures you can find underground.
Underground?
I've never found one.
Ever.
That's real?
It's starting to get dark.
I found one the other day.
What?
I've never found one ever.
Let's build a small home up here.
And by home, I mean we're going mining.
Heck yeah.
More coal.
In fact...
Torch?
Torch this place up?
Why can't I make a torch?
You need coal?
You guys.
I have 40 coal!
And I have sticks right here!
Stick and coal.
Why wasn't it showing up in my inventory?
Oh gosh.
That's strange.
Or like, not inventory, but in my recipes is what I meant to say.
Money!
More food.
Come back.
Come back dinner.
And dinner too.
What are those?
Uh oh, things are starting to appear.
What is that?
I thought it was a pillager at first.
We're probably safe over here.
Dinner and supper.
They won't come all the way over here.
Right?
We're probably fine.
I'm making a stone sword.
And I'm making a...
Good thing I made a stone sword.
Yeah, that's right.
He gave me iron!
Lucky guy.
Alright, we're making a furnace.
For a chicken.
Phew.
Can I make a shield?
I think it's two, right?
Oh no!
I need more wood.
Alright, we'll make a shield.
Eventually.
Oh,
whoops.
I just realized that.
I'm looking around.
I'm searching the premises.
So far...
Not so bad.
More iron.
Back in my day, we didn't have the recipe book.
Okay.
Okay, grandpa.
Back in my day, kids just learned.
You
guys, I didn't get the shi...
Oh, my precious...
What is this?
These piggies look so silly!
They look diseased, actually.
Wait, I didn't get to show you!
I didn't get to show you the fireflies!
I didn't get to show you.
I didn't get to... They were right here where we spawned!
Maybe Cortex is a five gifted.
We didn't explore at all.
I got creeper on manned!
Oh, man.
No!
Oh, man!
Yeah, next spawn will be a desert for sure!
Desert world!
You guys, this is real.
This is actual manifesting.
This is actual real manifestation.
Here we go!
I'm closing my eyes!
3, 2, 1!
I...
I don't...
I don't understand.
How 3 for 3?
How this is possible?
What is that over here?
Is this an ocelot?
It's a panda!
Oh my gosh!
I don't understand.
Is it actually the name?
That can't be true.
I need to try something.
I need to...
Think of another biome!
Wait, swamp!
Swamp?
I don't know!
Can I spawn a world called my dad came back from getting milk?
I can't believe it!
I'm still... I'm still shooketh.
I'm not gonna make a new world.
I don't wanna...
This is my... I don't...
My luck will surely run out.
I can't even punch trees.
I can't do anything.
I'm too... I'm too stunned to speak.
You want the seed?
Just like... Oh no!
The world's on fire!
That's the way I'm gonna... I'm gonna be born.
I know!
You're a rockstar!
I'm too...
Oh, there we go.
Ok.
I'm too stunned to speak!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the seed.
There you go.
Jump?
Ok!
Ok.
Cute!
I feel like I should have made some torches.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna die.
Tiny zombie.
I'm gonna die by tiny zombie.
We made it.
Sweep!
Where is that guy?
Stupid tiny zombie.
Oh my gosh.
Manifestation is real.
Hot dog.
This is the universe's way of making it up to you for the Ender Dragon collab with Doki.
But this is the one time I wanted to explore!
This is the one time I was like, ok guys...
We're gonna explore.
It's gonna be whatever.
It's gonna be just chill exploration.
It doesn't matter.
There's no end goal except finding the things.
Maybe we'll find a village at least so I can get some food.
Let's go try and find a village I guess.
I have literally nothing.
I'm too... wait!
I think I see a well at least.
Let's see.
Maybe there's a village over here.
Why not try creative?
Because I wanted to explore and find the biomes.
I wanted to explore and find them, but...
We're here I guess.
Wow, the... what's it called?
The lush biome is really huge here.
Yeah, Camel is desert only.
Dang it.
I was hoping it was the top of an actual...
house.
The windy sounds kind of sound like a...
like a creeper coming up.
I have no brush.
I have no food.
I have... I have no words.
I have nothing.
Oh here, maybe we can get some food.
Come here.
Come here, bunny.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
You... you didn't say anything.
Everything's fine.
Come here.
You're my only hope!
Obi-Wan!
Thank you.
What do you mean no guys?
I can't... I have no other option.
Unless you want me to never run again.
Alright.
Gosh, why is Minecraft have to be so realistic?
You need food for...
for doing things.
So lame, this baby.
Babies give nothing.
Come here.
Got a lucky foot.
Let's see if we can find a village.
And I'll go punch these trees.
At least we have these trees to punch, I suppose.
Oh, I hear a spider.
Maybe there's a... what's it called?
Underneath the...
Probably a...
Not a cave.
Mineshaft.
Dinogon!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
You really needed a lucky foot.
Is streamer luck real?
Okay, I'm finally playing the game again.
I'm finally done being stunlocked.
I'm playing the game.
I'm punching trees.
I'm done being stunlocked.
I love the little leaves.
The dropping leaves that they added.
It's so cute.
Okay, what else can we find around here?
And the flowers that they added to the cactus?
Also very cute.
Big fan, big fan.
Wow, the lush biome is huge.
Look at all these azaleas.
There's a cave biome below you.
I know.
Turtle!
Welcome to membership!
Aventurine, welcome to membership!
Thank you guys.
Is this a new Minecraft song?
No, it's my own original song.
Actually.
It's my own original BGM, if you like it.
You can listen to it anytime... Oh gosh, it's starting to get dark.
Village?
Come here, bunny.
Me too.
Sorry.
I was hoping we'd find...
I feel like you get so much better luck with spawning...
When you're running kind of close-ish to a...
To a village over all three things that we...
Well, I guess the firefly one isn't so difficult, but...
Alright, we are...
So dead.
I'll just keep running.
I'll just run and I won't stop running.
Oh wow, that's like the smallest ruined portal I've ever seen.
There's literally nothing here.
Maybe there's some stuff though.
Oh, they're all below me.
A lodestone.
We got some food.
We got some stuff.
I'll take the armor.
I'll take everything.
I'll take the clock.
That's good, actually.
Let's rearrange some things a little bit.
Whatever is below me is so close below me.
Like I can hear everything creeping and crawling around.
Alright.
I'm not gonna waste my sword on... Okay, let's just keep running.
Wait, can you not eat the melon slice?
Oh my God.
You can't eat the melon?
Just kidding, we're so dead.
They're for potions.
We're so dead.
It's got metal in it.
Never stopped me before.
What can I say?
I'm a ghost.
Ah, let's see.
Isn't life just so funny?
You know, we get some of the luckiest...
Some of the...
Some of the luckiest...
Spawns.
And yet, here I am.
Just...
You're cracking up?
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
I haven't cracked up in a while.
I was really looking forward to cracking up.
Can you stop being creepy at my feet, please?
I don't have enough food to, like, book it, you know?
Better hope a spider doesn't spot you.
Oh, it won't.
That would be, like, too unlucky, you know?
We can always build up.
There's always up.
Watch.
Right over there.
I predict.
Right on the other side of that hill.
Is a village.
I bet on it.
Bet on it.
I bet you.
What should we bet?
What are we betting?
Look, it's already halfway through the night.
We now know, because we have a clock.
We're betting...
One snake figurine.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Isn't this the type of zombie that doesn't die in sunlight?
No.
I'm betting you in my bed.
Oh my gosh.
Chiara, ruse.
Chiara, you're gonna have to fight.
Look, I'm a sought after commodity right now.
You're gonna have to do better than that.
Look how popular I am.
Freaky Wawa.
Freaky Wawa is actually so perfect.
You know how I have freak phantom glasses?
Someone needs to make ones for Chiara that say freak on one side and then Wawa.
Or freaky on one side and then Wawa on the other side.
Freaky Wawa.
Oh, there's another guy.
Gosh, I'm too popular.
All the husks want me.
Look, they're groaning trying to get to me.
Freaky Wawa.
Hashtag freaky Wawa.
No!
Another player has joined the team.
I don't even think this creeper knows what he's...
Does he even know I'm up here?
Does this guy even know?
Or he's just here to join in on the party, yeah?
You think?
He doesn't even... Oh gosh.
Oh no, no, no.
There's a witch over there.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, no.
Do you guys enjoy this ASMR?
He just wants to mosh.
We're so fine.
New girl at work?
Just quit after one week on the job?
No way.
I'd creep on you any day.
Tag yourself.
Oh wait.
Oh no.
Oh wait, there's two creepers now!
Uh, guys?
Tag yourself.
Which one are you?
All of them.
Left one, that's you.
Creeper on the left.
I'm the spider.
You're keeping a safe, respectable distance and we all...
We all really appreciate that in these trying times.
Look at their moshing!
Give me something to break!
About your fucking face!
If the zombies are set on fire later, shouldn't it logically set the creepers off?
No...
Why is there a normal zombie over there?
How curious.
It's almost sunlight!
The sun will be rising!
And then we'll go over there and we'll bet.
You're standing on wood.
Skelly?
There's no Skelly around.
We're OK.
Oh, here comes another guy.
Are you kidding me?
How is she going to escape?
Very carefully.
We're going to be fine.
Look, this creeper doesn't care.
Oh, nevermind.
This menu is popping off.
Why am I doing so well in my Minecraft era?
I think I might have to build up more.
Then they'll lose interest.
And then we'll run.
They're not losing interest.
They're not losing interest, actually.
What a beautiful sunrise.
Guys, are you enjoying all the new Minecraft features?
That I'm so easily able to show off to you guys.
Are you entertained?
Sunlight.
Soon, things will catch on fire.
Fire.
Why aren't they catching on fire?
See?
Wait.
Husks don't burn?
Come here.
I need food.
I
just wanted a snack.
Oh, they lost interest.
They lost interest.
Village incoming.
3, 2, 1.
Village!
Oh my gosh, Lottie!
Thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
Is this ever going to be the last Lottie rain?
No.
Please, why am I so bad?
Please, this is the worst.
At that point, I don't think I deserved to kill him.
He was too good.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you for the rain, Lottie.
No.
I'm currently having my luckiest and unluckiest ever Minecraft ever of my career.
Oh my gosh, finally, we can play the game.
Here we go, guys.
Wait, were there more?
Andrickos, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Pyrobug, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Teeqoven, yanyan, thank you for the gifted.
Spank, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Ikeastif2, thanks for the gifted.
Bankido, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
RugboyRabbit, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Raymac, thanks for the gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Okay.
Alright.
We're playing Minecraft now.
Holy moly.
So, to give raiders any kind of...
So I came in being like, I'm going to play in hardcore mode.
And I'm going to play until I can find the Creaking, which was the first thing that I wanted to find.
It's a new biome called the Pale Garden.
I was like, we're going to find that, we're going to go find that guy, and we're going to be spooked, and it's going to be fun adventure times.
And then my first world, I spawned right into it.
And then...
Speedyfire, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys so much for all the gifted memberships.
And then, I was like, okay, I died in that world because I was trying to show off.
I was like, hey, check it out.
But in world 2, I was just like, all right, we're going to go find fireflies, which you can only find, I guess...
You can find them in swamps, but also in rivers, next to rivers.
And so I was like, okay, we're going to...
We're going to go find that.
And then I spawned right next to some fireflies.
And then in the third world, I was like, okay, we're going to go find a desert, because they added some things in the desert.
And wouldn't you know...
Wouldn't you know...
Where am I right now?
It's so...
Curious.
Isn't it...
Isn't it just too curious how this is happening?
I might be cheating.
I don't know.
Manifested.
Hold on, double BGM.
All right.
Onwards.
We're trying to find a village.
Oh, and dinner.
Nice.
Yeah, baby.
Will we find a village?
Actually, I don't think so.
This is looking pretty desolate.
What did I say I was going to go find now?
I can't remember.
I can't remember anymore.
They're too small for meat.
Fossil?
I didn't say that.
You guys said that.
You were like, go find a fossil.
Fossil.
He's too good.
He's juking.
Oh my gosh.
How am I so bad actually?
There we go.
How am I so bad?
I feel like I have no purpose.
At least we can cook these bunnies now.
Here we're going to go defeat the wither.
I was?
Okay.
Gotta go defeat the wither.
I love these big coal veins.
Oh yeah, baby.
We all have a purpose.
Well...
What's mine?
To hunt?
To make spooky noises?
To open your cabinets?
To...
To possess your body?
I demand fossil.
But it's like so difficult, no?
How does one find a fossil?
Explain, everybody.
Everybody explain.
How does one find a fossil?
I've never found one ever before.
You just have to dig.
Really, that's it?
Look in the mirror.
Fossil world.
I've never found one before.
Truly.
We would need a whole lot more coal.
And how deep are they?
Am fossil.
Kiara, crazy idea for your next video.
For your next am video.
Am fossil.
You should do that next time you have...
New debuts.
Am fossil.
I guess we'll go digging.
A cosplay is you!
Oh my gosh, you would look so cute.
Good.
Guys, we got Kiara in a maid outfit.
Mission accomplished.
Sunken ship?
You saw one.
Oh my gosh, it's like so intact.
Wow.
Okay, we'll go get it.
Give me a second.
I feel I must make some proper food.
So while... Let's see.
While this is cooking...
While this is cooking, we'll keep digging.
Your purpose is to be the ultimate ghost maid idol.
One of those is optional, I suppose.
But not the ghost and not the maid.
Okay, and over here are some more.
Some more.
Camel!
Can I put the...
Hold on.
Can we put the horse... I mean, no, he's not a horse.
Oh no, we need just a normal saddle, right?
Dang, I was about to drip...
Guys, do you see the sun at the moment?
That's not good.
We're so cooked.
Nah.
We can do this.
Make a bunch of torches.
Or eight of them.
Hold on.
I'm getting lost in the sauce.
There we go.
Okay.
Torch.
Tons of them.
Fill this little island with torches.
This is our safe zone.
It's not an island, but you get it.
You get what I mean.
This is a safe... This is a safe zone.
This is where nothing will spawn.
I come back here...
It's totally good.
Maybe.
Totally is... Okay.
It might be a bit like, you know...
No, please come back.
Please come back!
I need dinner.
I need dinner!
Are you big?
He looked kinda small.
I wasn't fast enough.
Okay.
We're fine.
Maybe a tiny house?
Houses are for losers.
I mean, you're totally right.
I probably should have a tiny house, but...
If that camel is fine, I'm fine.
Camel is our indicator.
Okay!
This is pretty...
This feels spawn-proof, right?
Alright, let's go yo-ho.
Yo-ho, yo-ho!
Powers live for me!
I can't see anything!
Alright, it's nice and lit.
Craft a boat.
You're so much smarter than me.
Doors!
Guys, can you tell it's been a long time since I've played Minecraft?
Can you tell?
It's been a while.
Since I've played a Minecraft game.
Yes.
It's because I don't have a server to play with anybody on.
It's fine playing by myself too, but it's not the same, you know?
I thought about maybe making like an indie...
Or like, yeah, some sort of indie VTuber server.
Or just like, you know...
I say indie, but like a server that anybody can join in.
Okay, set the door down.
Uh, shoot.
Go, go, go, go, go...
Why couldn't I set it down?
Were those slabs or something?
Oh gosh.
Please, let me in.
Let me in.
I can't see!
I can't see anything.
There it is.
Yeah!
Nice find.
Come on, please.
I'm stuck!
Alright, let's go to the top.
Doki SMP player base yearns for Mint Phantom.
What?
Oh, is that Doki's server?
I thought that was for her members or whatever.
No?
A door.
Potato!
Carrot!
Oh yeah, baby.
Let's take the paper too.
Alright, nice.
Nice, nice.
That's good for us, I suppose.
I can't see anything, you guys.
It's so bad.
I wish I could put something even on like...
Treasure map.
I'm taking everything.
If only you had a light.
I'm literally... It's in my hand.
What?
You think...
If only you had a light.
Yeah, in the total darkness that is night.
Yeah.
And underwater where fire totally burns.
Shall we go?
Hunt for treasure!
South.
See, pickles emit light.
Do they... If they are in your hand...
It's like the one time I... So sad, don't have shaders, you know?
When you are like... Needing...
A light source.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
How far is this?
How far down is this?
Southeast.
Wait, I'm going south.
And then this is... So, southeast.
I'm a little directionally...
Impaired.
Don't shoot me.
Mesa biome.
Biome.
I think we are gonna... I think we are on the brink of discovery.
Of a village.
I believe.
It's like right there.
I can taste it.
I can hear the villagers, their cries to be pillaged.
Wait, the fireflies!
Do you guys see that right there?
The little glowing light?
Those are fireflies!
Kojima-san, watch Captain America...
What just hit me?
Oh, I think it's drowned.
Look at them!
They are so cute!
They are so pretty!
You can hear them buzzing.
Back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up, back it up...
They are mine now.
Ok, now they are ours.
Anyway, what was I saying?
Oh, there was a super chat.
Hold on.
Oh, I passed it!
One second.
Let me read it, let me read it.
I did see his tweet about watching Captain America and said he was confused.
I'm so... Ok.
I know it's not Kingdom Hearts' fault.
But I still blame Kingdom Hearts.
Ok, it's just like a personal thing.
But having...
The fact that...
To follow a mainline story, you have to literally...
And I blame Kingdom Hearts because...
They had the mobile game that you had to play to also understand the story, you know?
And that's basically what it is here now with Marvel.
You have to watch every single show.
You have to just dedicate your life, your afterlife...
Any of your time...
Oh wow, skelly party.
To...
To the single...
Content.
Sorry.
The music scared me.
I just watched recaps on YouTube?
That's so smart.
But yeah, I only blame Kingdom Hearts because, you know, it's just a personal thing.
This music with the...
With the fireflies.
It's so beautiful.
There, there, there, there.
Oh my gosh, look at all the fireflies!
It sounds like summer.
We can watch the fireflies while the sky is on fire.
Fireflies!
Dummy.
I think they only come out at night though, obviously.
You would not believe your eyes.
Let's take these ones too.
Next time it's night.
This song is so pretty, what the heck?
I love Minecraft music.
You would not believe your eyes.
Look at the piggies!
Oh, their curly tail!
Let me see your butt.
You're gonna be on my plate tonight.
Come here.
Dinner time.
Nice.
I wonder if we can find a...
What's it called?
I've always wanted to... I think I've only found one like ever naturally once.
But the...
The jungle ruins?
They're so cool.
I wish there were more structures like that, you know?
They're so fun.
They're so neat.
Coco beans?
Nice.
Look at these guys!
They have the horns, but they're not so fuzzy as the...
As the...
The treasure.
What treasure?
Oh, my treasure from the boat.
You're right.
Let's go find treasure.
Where are we?
I passed over it, so all I have to do is go backwards.
Don't worry.
Where's my boat?
My boat is...
Over here?
I thought you meant treasure from...
The...
From the ruins.
There's my boat.
Okay, we just gotta go backwards.
Yeah, Chiara is the only one allowed to backseat.
And it's not really backseating, it's her just, you know...
I mean, is an Oshi ever wrong?
No.
That's just a fact.
Your Oshi is never incorrect.
Wait, uh...
Yeah, that's where the skelly party was.
Warm cows.
Remember when your Oshi told you to play Sisyphus?
And you know what?
I learned a lesson.
About, wait...
Myself, and...
About...
You know, a lot of things.
I think it's right...
It shows on the map, but...
We might have to...
We might have to walk.
Alright.
For dinner!
I hate catching the rabbits.
Good enough.
Alright.
Onwards.
So it's like...
North, east, right?
This is like the food run.
I'm finally getting a lot of food.
East, and this is north?
Northeast, yeah.
I'm going the right way.
Thank you.
Finally getting food, I've been starving.
I've been starving in all my other playthroughs!
Guys, remember that village I talked about?
It's gonna happen.
These biomes always have a village.
I love the curly ones.
I love the curly... Do they all have curly butts?
I just never noticed.
They look like they have flatter ears too.
These don't look like pigs anymore, they look like dogs.
I thought my heart couldn't fit anymore VTubers, but Mint is a ghost.
Also, I'm glad you enjoyed the Fireball animation.
Thanks Fireball!
I love that show.
It's so witty, it's so cute, it's so fun.
No!
Don't be greedy.
They are more boar-like, you think?
Is that an armadillo?
Armadillo!
He's so cute.
The loot?
We're getting there.
Armadillo.
Uh...
It's like right...
Over there!
Oh, come on.
I mean, I could tell from the map that I'd be in the sea, but...
What?
It's like...
Do you think there's a chance it could be exposed?
You got a door, I got a single door.
Let's see, am I on...
I'm like basically on it.
I didn't make one.
It's fine though.
Oh!
It's right there!
We got it!
Yippee!
Water breathing!
Ok, let's get rid of some stuff that we don't need.
This and this.
Oh my gold!
My cooked salmon!
Heart of the sea.
We don't really need the Heart of the Sea, I don't think, right?
I'm not trying to build a...
A thingy.
My door?
I can always make a new door.
Brown sheep!
Come on, you're gonna make me a bed.
You're gonna make me a bed.
Alright, hold on.
Let's set up some stuff here.
Where did I put my crafting table?
Didn't I just make a crafting table?
Inventory chaos.
Don't worry about it.
Where...
What?
Twig!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Did I not make the table?
What?
I literally...
I don't know.
OK
I don't think I have enough for a furnace.
I don't.
That's OK.
Bread.
I don't need you.
Let's go...
Bed.
Bed!
Bed, bread!
We finally have a bed, everybody.
We finally have a bed!
Now you can respawn, except I can't.
We're in hardcore.
I can't.
There's no respawning.
Hot dog, indeed.
Alright, what are we doing?
The bed?
OK.
So we got a bed.
Let's go mine some...
I don't need that.
Where was the treasure chest?
It was like over here, right?
I think I left my table down there.
Yeah, I did.
Or my... table.
My... door.
I'm just gonna put the...
I'm just gonna put the treasure map back in there.
I'm gonna put some other stuff in there that we don't need.
OK.
Make some chests.
How do you make a bundle?
How do you make the bundles?
The things that you can actually carry with you.
Chests are so...
Chests are useless to make unless you are settled down, you know?
But we're not.
We're adventurers.
Leather and string.
I have rabbit hide.
It's basically some leather.
Alright, let's just go...
Dig some stone.
Real quick.
Right there.
Excuse me.
Yeah, OK.
That was a single stone.
Latte!
Welcome to my mushroom patch.
Cool.
Anymore?
I don't wanna dig up...
I don't have any... I don't have a shovel, so...
Too lazy to make one.
Too lazy to make one, not too lazy to run all over a map, though.
In search of stone.
Congrats on your stone.
Thank you.
Run!
Alright, we shall dig for stone.
Just like the ancestors did.
Oh, I just noticed I have this azalea.
Where did this come from?
Can I put the flower on top?
Oh my gosh!
It's too cute!
Wait, imagine you have the one that has the flowers on it.
Imagine.
This guy is out here searching for his family.
Don't worry.
You'll go back.
You'll join them.
Fucking stone.
We're gonna waste our stone to make a stone shovel.
Our single stone.
Dude.
Now we can make a furnace.
Good stuff.
We'll grab some extra, even.
Putting that stone to good use.
Absolutely.
All stone is good stone.
Spend money to make money.
Exactly!
Exactly.
I don't think anything will spawn in there.
Seems too light still.
Okay.
Furnace time.
For.
Furnish.
Okay.
Lode stone is for when you die, right?
Doesn't it also act as a...
As a...
Like a spawn point?
I've never made one because they only recently...
Made it easier to be able to get one.
Oh, it's for the compass.
Just kidding.
Where did all my coal go?
All the coal I mined.
Did I spend it all on torches?
You left it in the other...
I left it in the other furnace.
Furnace.
We can go back.
We know the direction.
We know.
We are adventurers and we have the adventure sense.
Can we though?
Yeah, we can.
We can.
And it will be so easy to find.
I love all the coral.
It's so pretty and cute.
I love it very much.
It was like right around the corner.
It's like right over here.
It's like right there.
Right there.
Right down there.
Right there?
Wait.
I think we are okay.
Right...
No, it was a little more...
Is that the sun going down?
No, it's midday.
Right...
Right there!
See?
A pirate's favorite leather.
Remember to eat.
I know that's why we needed the furnace.
We got a little lost in the sauce.
But we are back to our safe base.
See?
Now we can eat.
I thought it was R.
Apparently not.
And I had to walk the plank earlier.
And you should too.
Guys, I'm sorry that I'm not doing anything.
I'm sorry that this Minecraft stream has...
Zero direction.
You know?
It's just...
Maybe we are finding our purpose.
Somehow.
Someway.
You know?
Everybody finds their purpose at their own pace.
Sometimes life hands you exactly what you need.
But you say, I know.
It wasn't about getting it the easy way.
It was about the journey.
But when you don't have the journey, what do you do?
What do you do when you've been deprived of the journey?
Wander with friends.
I'm alone on this boat.
This is a solo mission.
I'm gonna take all these back.
And we're gonna abandon this place.
Let's cook while we take all of our torches back.
Did you think they were for keepsakes?
No.
Absolutely not.
What's something we should try and find?
Not... Don't say fossil.
I guess we could just dig.
And dig and dig.
And dig and never stop digging.
Just in a hole.
One line all the way.
We could just go forever.
I mean, that's the mine part of Minecraft, is it not?
Diamonds?
We could find diamonds.
I thought that was a little baby...
I thought that was a baby dolphin for a second.
A village?
The village is in our hearts.
Clearly my sense was completely wrong.
I could have sworn I smelled a village around the corner.
I really did.
Maybe I just need a shower.
I don't know.
Cherry forest?
That would be fun.
Okay, we'll try for cherry.
Let's just go on the ocean blue and see where it takes us.
I think that's all of them.
Yep.
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna need you to speed this up a little bit now.
I'm gonna need you to be a little bit faster.
Um...
Uh...
You know...
I'm gonna need you to be like 10 times faster than what you are right now.
I'm gonna need you to really pick up the pace.
Uh...
We'll take this.
Yep.
I could sleep, but...
What's the fun in that?
It's okay.
We're armed and we're dangerous.
Wait, I missed one.
Haha.
We're armed and we're dangerous.
Nothing would mess with us, probably.
Oh!
Yes, let's go.
See ya, suckers!
Again?
What do you mean again?
What are you guys saying?
Why are you guys saying again again?
What?
I'm confused.
It's from Marvel Rivals?
Why would you bring that into my chat?
What?
Why would you even...
Don't bring your brain right here.
Nasty.
You are not welcome in this space.
Haha.
You are not welcome here.
Not Marvel Rivals, brain right!
I don't even know...
I don't even know anything about Marvel, you guys.
Is Iron Man Marvel?
Wait, is this one of those underground...
Temples?
Do you think there will be...
Sea zombies here?
If only I had a duster.
I don't see any, guys.
Oh, I don't see anything, actually.
I don't have a...
No, I didn't...
Why did I come down here?
I don't have anything.
I thought there might be...
Ok, that guy has a trident.
We need to leave.
I see him.
There is a guy over there with a trident.
But there is the thing.
The movie?
Wait, is he... No, that guy?
Wait, from the movie, the thing...
Is in Marvel Rivals?
One does not simply say...
Marvel Rivals...
And not expect a...
A who?
Oh, from Fantastic Four.
Uh...
I got my hopes up.
I thought there was actually...
Something good in...
I thought...
I thought there was actually...
Peak.
Nevermind.
John Carpenter is the thing?
Yeah.
Oh, there is some...
Glow squids down there.
Wow, this is like the most vast ocean ever.
We are...
We are so lost.
Such a hater.
No, I just really don't know anything about Marvel.
Or...
Comic book stuff in general.
I'm an anime nerd.
It's like, you know...
The comic book nerds...
Would always look down on the anime nerds.
So it's just instilled in my...
You know, in my soul to be like...
Comic books suck.
We are still in the desert, baby!
Wait, did I...
Wait, did I accidentally turn around?
When I circled around?
Did I accidentally turn around?
No?
Wait...
Hold on, let's go see if our...
If our safety island is still there.
Wait!
Look, a ruined portal!
I don't think that was there before.
No!
You are...
You are... You suck.
I don't need the lodestone.
Golden apple!
Okay.
No,
this looks different.
I just bought a comic book while listening to you.
It was the opposite when I was in school.
The anime and manga kids thought comic books and western graphic novels weren't sophisticated enough for their ultra-culture taste.
Nerds are so funny.
I'm a better nerd than you.
My nerd tastes are better than your nerd tastes.
You know who doesn't care and just...
Is so chill and like, you know...
I need to make a feather duster.
Anyway, you know who doesn't care about anything like that?
Train otaku.
People who just like trains...
Are so joyous.
And so...
They just...
They're so...
They stay in their lane.
They stay in their train.
They stay on their track.
Made me Damon in the Odyssey.
They are wholesome.
Yeah, they're wholesome.
And they're like, I just...
I like trains.
If you want to know about trains...
I'll tell you.
See?
I didn't turn around again.
I think the biome is just this huge.
Hazel, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Wait, so did I turn around this time?
No.
We're continuing onward.
I think.
The train and plane otaku are at war?
Girl, what?
No, they're not.
Don't tell me that.
They're not at war.
Why can't we coexist?
I don't know, humans gotta make everything a competition.
Everything's a peepee contest.
Speaking of manga, have you read Strike It Rich?
I haven't.
I saw a video the other day...
of a...
I think I saved it.
I sure hope I did.
Now I'm trying to think if I saved it or not.
But it's a place where you can go on little tiny trains.
And like...
On the inside, they look like real trains.
And you can drive them.
And I was like, maybe...
when I go back...
to Japan, I can try that.
Here comes the sun.
Wait.
Wait, I forgot.
The firefly bush.
Here comes the sun.
And I say...
It's alright.
So cute.
So pretty.
What I really wanna do...
is whenever I...
Whenever...
Bozo.
Whenever I can play on a server again with other people and feel motivation to build and, you know, actually play and have fun with friends...
I want to...
have like a firefly lined path and then if you cover the area with like moss or something other things won't spawn.
I saw a video recently of a love hotel that had a train themed room.
I think that's kinda similar.
I don't think so.
Is it true that you can't go to a love hotel unless you... Like, what if I wanted to go to a love hotel by myself?
Would they not let me get my own room?
I'm just trying to sleep.
You can?
No way, really?
I thought I read once that you couldn't.
That you had to be like a couple.
You can!
Is it clean?
Depends on the hotel.
I guess they probably get a bunch of people for like the fun...
For the fun rooms, right?
Well, I mean, they're all supposed to be fun.
But you know, like the themed rooms.
I probably wouldn't lay under the sheet.
An escape room?
Oh my gosh, an escape room love hotel?
Would be awesome.
But I've never done an escape room before.
Actually, I might panic.
I might bring a tent.
Sounds like a doujin plot.
It does.
I'm gonna tell Ayami mama.
Mama!
I have inspiration for you.
Are we gonna find another creaking?
Village doko?
I think this is the longest I've been without ever finding a village.
Like in a game.
We've found every biome that I've been looking for.
And never found the village.
Wow, this is a tiny island.
How much you wanna bet something epic is under here?
Something huge.
How much you wanna bet the stronghold is under this island?
Under this tiny island.
There's a stronghold or something.
Shall we dig here?
Shall we dig?
One dollar.
Just found Sicily.
If you see a giant cyclops, say your name is nobody.
Let's dig straight down.
Let's dig straight down, baby.
Hold on.
Before we do that though, let's collect some wood.
Two dollar.
Tree fruity.
This is such a small little biome.
Biome.
I guess if you wanted...
I guess if you wanted some...
What's the word?
Is that a creeper?
Right there?
I've been watching a lot of Minecraft creepypasta videos.
It is!
Oh my gosh, it's a creeper.
And they'll be like...
They'll be like, if you see this in your world, delete it right now.
I watch them when I go to sleep.
It'll be like...
If you...
see this, delete your world.
And it'll be like a...
It'll be like a really obscure mob or something stupid.
If you see this.
Turns out it was Larry.
Evil Larry.
Okay.
I think we should even dig right here, actually.
Do we need horse armor?
I thought maybe we might find a horse eventually, but I don't think we do.
We don't need books.
I'm not reading today.
We don't need a glistening melon slice.
I'll bring the potion of water.
I don't have a ton of food.
Oh wait, I never cooked my potato.
But honestly, this isn't for...
We're not living here, you know.
We'll probably die in here.
Truthfully.
Quite honestly.
We'll probably die in here.
And that's okay.
What am I keep picking up?
Oh.
Okay.
Yep.
Let's...
You can build a diamond sword.
I could.
Let's actually make an iron sword for now.
I got two furnaces.
Do I have any armor?
I'm mixing my worlds up.
I'm getting everything all mixed up from before.
We got a stone shovel.
We'll just go with that for now.
Here we go.
We're digging down.
Straight down.
I can't see anything.
Fearless.
That's not true.
I have a lot of fears.
But today...
I'm gonna face, gonna face, gonna face my fears.
Gonna face, gonna face.
I bet the stronghold is right under here.
We're gonna make a new pickaxe?
Where is it?
Hmm?
Oh, there.
Nice.
Stay safe.
Have a great trip in Japan.
Thanks, Nan!
Thank you.
This is scary.
Don't be scared.
This is adventure.
This is what the game is all about.
Oh!
This is what it's all about, baby.
Did you know that?
I did.
I did know.
I don't even have a shield.
I just realized.
Maybe I should make one.
Hmm.
Flashba...
Biome.
It's so lit.
It's like, not lit, but you know, it's so bright.
And I fell in water.
Lucky us.
Any axolotls?
About?
Hot dog.
Hot dog, indeed.
It looks just like gold.
Try princess.
Thank you.
Should we keep going down?
Or...
That's kind of far down.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Oh.
That guy has an enchanted bow.
What do you need that for?
What do you need that for, huh?
Lava.
Guys, I don't think the stronghold is down here.
But we'll keep going.
Right through here.
How far are we?
Negative 15?
We're at like nothingness.
We're like at nothing.
She's never gonna come out of this cave anymore.
I'm gonna find a fossil!
I'm
finding a fossil, Chiara!
Gonna find lava at this rate?
Maybe.
Fine, I'll dig sideways.
Wait, not that way.
This way.
Here we go.
This is it.
This is the adventure we yearned for.
We're at negative 42.
We'll definitely find diamonds.
Gold!
We struck gold!
If this were the gold rush, I would be a hot commodity.
We're rich!
Have you ever done one of those?
So, for those, I guess maybe it's kind of like... I don't know if it's an American thing or not.
There's places where you can get bags of dirt and sift for gold.
And, you know, you just do exactly that.
You just hope that you get gold.
Gold panning!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
They're usually... I don't think they're legit usually, but they're still fun.
The adventure...
Stop!
You're so on brand.
I love it.
Actually, I feel bad for telling her to find the fossil.
She'll be digging for years!
No, we'll get lucky!
We're going to strike it rich!
We're going to...
We're going to strike rich, right guys?
We're still alive in this hardcore world.
We lived through creepers and husks and drownings and everything.
And now we're going to find a diamond and...
Actually, I think we're about to find an exit.
Oh, there it is.
Shoot.
I don't...
I feel better in my hole.
Don't mine at night.
What is this creepypasta?
Is this a lush cave?
It is!
Yeah, it actually is.
Change direction?
OK.
I think it's mostly safe because...
Luckily this biome makes it...
safe to...
You know, safer.
What are we at?
Negative 51.
We're going to find diamond.
This way.
Yeah, the little branches make it...
lit up, you know?
Oh no, not a year long Minecraft series!
I'm going to mine out the entire world.
I'm going to make sure there's not even a single block left of Minecraft.
Time to dig diagonally.
Shall we?
I literally dug for a year and only found five.
I've... I mean, I've played...
Wait, they're a little loud.
I've played so much Minecraft!
I never knew you could find a fossil.
Wait, did I leave my stuff up there?
It's OK, I have more.
I have another furnace.
Wait!
My coal!
Wait, I messed up!
Safe.
Saved, yeah.
All five of them.
Are you saying that even five coal isn't important?
Everybody is important.
OK.
Oops.
We're good.
Diagonal time.
I wish this block though wasn't so difficult to cut through.
Every five coal is important.
Coal is quite rare in this game.
You're being sarcastic, huh?
But it is actually kind of rare at this level.
You can't... You can't doubt that.
OK.
It is actually quite rare at this depth.
I never even knew about fossils until Kiara found one.
What was her... What was her...
What was her Y level when she found it?
I need to know.
Am I at the correct depth?
I mean, if there's no fossils...
I mean, if there's no coal, how would there be fossils?
I could be wrong, but don't fossils only spawn in some biomes?
It's a wide range of Y levels.
OK.
Yes, only deserts and swamps.
You mean the biome that I started at?
You mean the biome that I was literally trapped in for like two hours?
You mean that biome?
You mean the biome I just left before deciding that we were going to go find a fossil?
You mean the biome that I have to turn around...
You mean the biome that I literally traveled oceans across?
Oceans away from?
In fact?
I see.
I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Yep, yep.
Cool.
Very cool.
Hold on.
I'm not throwing that away, obviously.
I'm just eating some rabbit.
Guys, I think we might actually like...
die of starvation in here, maybe.
Just dig to our spawn.
Imagine I die.
OK, hold on.
Go into spectator mode.
And what if there was a fossil close to where I spawned at?
Would that not be so incredible?
I think we're also about to find an exit right here.
How deep
is this biome?
Why have I not found any diamonds yet?
What is this?
You guys, diamonds in 3...
2...
1...
And...
Diamond here!
Here!
What's the Y level?
We're at negative 52.
Must be a delay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I said to the person definitely not running this Minecraft server...
Diamonds...
in...
Wait, we're in the tough world.
Literally, the game just said tough.
I said, please, please, can I have diamonds, please?
And the game literally said, tough.
Oh, we just hit bedrock.
Yeah, tough luck.
Oops, sorry.
Please, please, can I have diamonds, please?
Can diamonds even spawn...
Oh, this low.
I guess so.
Uh-oh.
You guys hear that?
Must be nothing.
Just the wind.
Probably.
But if I...
If I go upwards, there might be diamonds by the lava.
Right?
Probably nothing.
It's nothing, no biggie.
Nice.
How would level...
I'm only level 10?
Don't be stressed.
Sounds like a plan.
Iron.
It's kind of big, actually.
No.
My apple.
There we go.
Sounds awfully close.
Okay.
Alright.
Lava pops.
You're worth more than any diamond I mine.
What, are you gonna sell me off or something?
We found the lava pit.
Indeed we did.
And we found a mineshaft.
Did we find diamonds?
Oh god.
No, no, no.
Please.
I don't have a water bucket.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's water right here.
Water, water, water, water!
As long as the skelly doesn't come out from behind that...
From behind that area.
We'll be safe.
Okay.
No.
I thought there was diamond up there, but it's...
Lapis.
We're okay.
In fact, I'm gonna do a little bit of...
This.
That.
Goodbye.
There we go.
There we go, yeah.
Safety.
Oh, I hear a spitter.
I don't really wanna go into the mineshaft.
Oh my god!
She survived and she gets diamonds.
I think I earned that!
I earned those diamonds.
I earned that, baby!
Oh my goodness.
Yurian!
Thank you for the diamond.
Alright, now let's go die.
We're gonna die, everybody.
Okay?
We're gonna die.
I'm done with this world.
It's time to die.
It's not a respectable death, but...
Can we walk into the lava like Terminator?
I guess we can do that instead.
Well, actually, I don't know where we are.
Live!
I'm alive somehow.
Another death cheated.
How do we get out of here though?
I don't even know where the lava is.
Oh, the lava...
Lava pops.
This side.
Wawa said live.
I think she said live.
Like, I'm alive!
Live!
Or...
The live stream is live, right?
Oh, I do have a shovel.
You're so right.
Oh my gosh, I almost really got...
Like, mega...
How do we get out of here?
No, don't die!
Kiwawa, I'm done with this world.
I'm done.
It's okay.
I can always make another...
Another...
Another hardcore world.
Actually, I wanted to...
Oh, I found it.
Oh my gosh, I finally found our way out.
It's okay, Kiwawa.
I'll be back.
Da-dun-dun-da-dun.
Oh!
My stuff even...
Yay!
Where it all began.
Wait, hold on.
Copy.
Paste.
Da-dun-dun-da-dun.
Oh, wait.
Single...
No, default.
Creative.
Create.
And then, hold on.
AppData.
I wanted to see...
Remember how I was just like...
Oh, wait.
What is it?
AppData.
Remember how I was just like, oh, I want to see what's around.
I'm looking at my screenshots.
Screenshots.
Teleport.
Teleport me.
Two.
Minus 44.
240.
Alright.
I was like, there's going to be something big down here.
There's going to be something big.
Remember?
Wait.
No, wait.
Hold on.
Let's see if we can find the...
The island!
If I had dug... I dug, I think, this way.
If I had dug that way.
I fell through here, remember?
I fell through here.
We saw these gold blocks.
And then I went this way.
If I had... If I had gone this way...
Actually, I would have been stuck in water.
Oh, actually, ok.
No, it was kind of diagonal.
It still would have been a bit of a trek to get to.
I was close though.
I knew.
I knew there was something big down here.
The diagonal guy was right!
VTuber!
Dig diagonally, VTuber!
I was a fool for not listening.
And I apologize.
I deeply regret my words and my actions.
Dang it.
I mean, I probably would have been freaking...
But look at this!
It's a trial with the...
The lush branches and stuff.
It's so pretty.
Well guys, this was fun.
Thank you for allowing me to play some Minecraft.
I was just in a Minecraft mood.
And somehow...
Somehow we saw everything that I wanted to show off.
Somehow.
Literally, so easily, in fact.
Too easily that I just kind of wandered around.
Doing nothing.
For some time.
Because I didn't know what to do.
Thanks for the stream, Minto!
Cool to see the new stuff in Minecraft.
Also, thanks for all the neuron activations you gave me whenever you mentioned Firefly.
Oh yeah, that's your girl, right?
What's... Is it Honkai?
Blonkai.
Okay,
I have another objective before we end the stream.
So basically, I'm going to set this place ablaze.
Right?
Basically, I'm flattening this land.
And then, I'm going to cover it in Firefly's bushes.
Yeah, hot dog.
And then, we're going to have a beautiful Firefly display when it comes to night time.
And I'll see you guys off.
I cannot set the mushrooms ablaze.
Unfortunately.
This is just the easiest way to flatten it, you know what I mean?
It's just the easiest way.
You know, if there was another easy way, I wouldn't have resorted to such violent measures.
But I just had to.
I just have to resort to such violent measures.
It's not my fault.
I don't want to do this.
It's not like I enjoy the pretty lights and everything.
What's not on fire?
Oh my gosh.
Burn it down, Minky.
I'm on fire myself.
No tree is spared.
Not enough spread yet.
Come on.
Come on, fire.
Aren't you supposed to be so fast and dangerous?
Oh my gosh, look at that.
It's really coming down now.
Okay, good.
Burn everything, baby.
Look at this.
Wow, it's kind of beautiful in its own way.
Stop her from cooking.
No!
If only we had a mushroom biome.
And look, the sun is going to be going down soonish.
The fires should be done by then.
And no more trees blocking the view.
Exactly.
I can't believe my luck today.
The universe is so funny.
The universe really likes to make me out to be a real clown.
We will have pure, unobstructed views of the fireflies.
Alright, now I can assist a little bit.
There we go.
Joker mint arc.
I've always been...
I've always been the Joker.
The Jonkler.
Okay.
Look at the fires desperately start trying to hold on.
Everything, everything will burn.
Okay.
It should be good.
I think.
Maybe I... I don't think I overdid it.
I was going to say maybe I overdid it a little bit, but no, it's okay.
It's fine, probably.
It's like...
It's like whatever.
Hi, Mint.
Hello.
Thanks for the superchat.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Are you planning on doing a real cover of Snake Eater at some point?
I just don't think I'm doing justice.
You know?
I like how the fire stacks.
Where's the sun?
Oh no, it's about to go down.
It's all about to go down.
Uh-oh, wait.
No, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait.
My plan is backfiring.
I need more time.
Go away, fireflies.
Not yet.
I don't think I needed to do the whole...
You know, I'm starting to think I might have overreacted.
Backfiring.
Starting to think maybe...
Starting to think maybe I overreacted a little bit.
That, this was a bit excessive.
No, no, no, no.
No.
What is a life of luxury if not a bit of excess?
Right?
Just don't look in the direction of the burnt trees.
Thank you for stealing my condiments.
I love me some comfy block game stream.
Thank you.
I'm glad you liked it.
Again, I apologize for directionless gaming.
But somehow we really gamed today.
Somehow.
Somehow things ended up becoming really goofy.
In terms of how the game just was so goofy to me.
Maybe I should have come up with a backup plan.
Like, haha, this will be a Minecraft world that I will continue on with and try to actually play and see through it to the end.
Hot dog, hot dog.
Alright, this should be good.
Just don't turn around.
We have our nice little plot of firefly land.
More directionless Minecraft streams.
Oh, wait.
More directionless Minecraft streams into my blood, please.
Okay.
Let's do time.
Set.
No.
I don't know how to do this.
Set.
Noon.
Time.
Set.
Night.
Wow.
I can't wait for this with the shaders.
This with the shaders will be so pretty.
I'm a pro composer making a snake eater cover.
You are?
Good luck.
It's like being in space.
Yeah.
This sounds so nice.
It's like...
There's like little red dots blinking around.
Do you guys see that?
Or is it...
Like blinking...
Yeah, I see it on OBS too.
They're like blinking...
I think they have like a little bit of a graphical error.
You guys don't see it?
The little red dots blinking around the...
Like in...
You don't see it?
Thank you for taking us to this grave of the fireflies.
Hold on.
I'm going to see if I can screenshot it.
Oh, it's not in the screenshot.
Oh, yes it is.
Yes, it is.
Hold on.
I'll show you guys.
Look at this.
You see...
You see those two red dots?
Or red lines?
You see them?
Yeah, they kind of flicker.
They flicker around the...
Around the...
Fireflies a bit.
I knew I wasn't crazy.
You'll see it now.
Probably.
Sorry if I just ruined this for you.
X-Files theme.
Boom.
Oh, you kind of lose it with the bitrate.
Oh no.
Even from far away!
Even from far away it's so awesome.
Wait, why was there so many and then I...
It's still on fire.
Hey!
Get out of here!
Okay.
Lots of fireflies.
Thank you guys!
Otsuminto.
Is there a way to toggle music in this game?
Is there a way to toggle music?
I wish.
Otsuminto!
Otsu...
Such a fun stream.
You're the best cosplayer ever.
Thank you daily dayo!
Thank you!
Otsuminto.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
And...
I'll see you guys...
When I see you next!
Bye bye!
This will be our exit music today.
We'll use this as our exit music today.
Bye bye!
Moi moi.
He can stay.
Thanks for making me!
Thank you!
Bye bye!
I
can't stop singing the little...
Red lines though.
Maybe I overloaded it.
There's so many guys over there and then a chicken.
Okay, actually I'm gonna go to my ending screen or else I'll never leave!
Bye!